I think that families can help their
kids get better food habits pretty
easily first of all have meals together
really simple thing have meals together
turn the television set off during the
meals if you don't want your kids eating
junk food don't have it in the house
teach kids where food comes from teach
them how its produced teach them how
about food miles teach them about
natural and organic teach them about all
of that have come teach kids how to cook
if you want your kids to have really
great involvement with food too like
food to be adventurous about it to eat
interesting things teach them how to
cook
you